all right lucky
lucky uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um originally
pasadena california
um i was raised in placements in foster
homes and juvenile halls most timer
tell me about your childhood you had
both parents it sounds like you didn't
no my mom left when i was five
and my dad we didn't get too long we
stopped talking about 11 to 12.
and then so how was your childhood oh
very
very messed up very messed up um i was
blessed by my uncle for two years when i
was a kid
um my dad used to
he'd be real aggressive with me he um
didn't like the fact that i had
hung out chose to hunger around black
people um
you used to be me call me [ __ ] lover
[ __ ] trader i mean race traitor [ __ ]
lover
um i remember a couple nights he made me
sleep in the backyard with my dog
in the in the uh broke down car and
watched me from his bedroom window
um such and such
and you went on your own at what age i
always said i was a
i was tv on my own around 1450. yeah you
joined the game
yeah i enjoyed the game about 13. but i
was completely on my own separated from
i was on the streets 1450. so you're
joining which gang
uh pasadena devil in blood so you're
blood yes sir
you're a white you're caucasian very
much and you're in a totally black gang
yes sir how is that um it's being that i
was
growing up in the 90s when it was really
the gang banging that you see nowadays
is not the gang banging that gang
banging is it's
now you're getting the what you would
say um placebo of
gang baby 90s it was more hands-on
so it was a little rough for me being
white for a black game
i had to prove myself to the blacks had
to defend myself from whites and
mexicans so
it was rough from not you've done prison
time
yes sir 13 years what was that for home
invasion
home invasion and uh s been known gay
member
so what do you credit about your
childhood that may have led you into
into this lifestyle
i wouldn't say i don't blame me joining
the lifestyle
see my way i think it's a little
different i don't blame me joining the
lifestyle on
my mom and dad not being there that's i
wasn't looking for
connections or it was
that's what interested me that's that's
what attracted me that's gaming i'm not
just gaming but
um the reality of life the
the waking up every day going to school
soccer practice after school
um pizza after the game back home
bed watch abc family that's that's
a small percentage of america very small
percentage everybody else is
abused homeless hurting hiding something
afraid and that's the reality situation
and it's not about going out to pull out
guns
because you can't just rock around they
could shoot somebody or what nights
somebody has come today community area
of town and
chose to try to bring harm or disrespect
it
such and so forth that's this but that's
what it used to be so
i think i don't know i credit i don't
know maybe my attitude just attributed
me gay men i don't know
but i i was i mean you could say i was
angry i was angry remember my dad
um heard about my mom you know
took a long time for me to get over my
mom leaving
broke a lot of trust with females
do you have relationships you've been
married or
no um you have kids not no kids um i'm
37.
um i spent from 21 to 33 in prison
um i was stabbed ten times in prison but
i don't relationship wise is
is every i've been in two relationships
and both relationships have been with
those females they've cheated on me
um even though
my mom leaving me [ __ ] it had me walking
with caution when it comes to relate
with females
are believing people say i still put my
heart on my sleeve
because i'm not i'm not behind the
scenes type of individual i
straightforward so i work my heart on my
sleeve and
i give my heart to the wrong people that
don't need it so it ends up
it's just as in life i gave my heart to
the wrong people and
just got [ __ ] over
i might be off the question a little bit
is just do you have friends
um
very seldom well college person a friend
they have to be real i got shot last
year and i was behind
someone who was acting like a friend um
i got shot at twice last year
and um
then i got shot at twice i got
my legs shattered uh 14 screws in there
then i was in a wheelchair for two
months then i went to jail for eight
months on
um [ __ ] by the police or six months
[ __ ] by police i get out of jail
and my girl at the time tells me that
she [ __ ] my homie why's in jail
so this last year has been a [ __ ]
you know is it hard being
you know being in prison and being white
even though you were a
blood gang how was that that's not
that's 13 years of war
that's um every tattoo i
on my body is from penitentiary um
white boys didn't like it too much but
my theory was
i wasn't that way on the street so why
am i gonna be that way in prison
um the whole fact of me being from my
neighborhood is me being from my
neighborhood i mean
what do i look like going to prison
letting this boy tell me if i don't obey
what he's talking about then i'm gonna
get hurt
so i chose to go with my homies and i
got stabbed in my
stomach my uh armpit slicing my arms
slicing my neck
just over the course of years the rights
so for 14 stitches on faces seven
stitches on that side
yeah what to are you using any of the
drugs that are
on the street do i usually drop some
shoes um i do uh
become a victim sometimes of uh things i
used to maintain
uh i smoke a lot of weed i'm weed head
i'll profess that all day every day um
sometimes i do meth
to uh i don't it calms me down focuses
me
not like other people i don't know i
like to read when i get you know
and the gang life for you has changed
you know it's changed since you started
right oh yeah yeah that's
it's and that's one of the reasons i
stick to myself
because now it's just you still consider
yourself a gang member
yeah yeah but you're just not doing the
same things no i'm not
i'm a gang member i'm just not out gang
banging
gang banging is fake it's phases you
know phases
and where do you think where do you
think you'll be in uh five ten years
on everything i loved a year ago i would
have been saying still um somehow
i mean god's gonna work out for me he's
gonna work my life out no matter what
but
last shot i've been saying god's gonna
put me on the house in the hills he's
getting something's just gonna you know
i've been through i lost too much of my
life
to keep on losing so you know but
i mean getting shot at and um
twice this last past year and
i'm i'm just tired police are asking me
i'm tired of i went to jail at least
nine times last year ten times
just in and out um i'm tired please
harassment i get shot at
i'm tired of people telling me they love
me don't love me um
i just i thank god for damn living
that's all
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in life yeah
don't let this world um take your
essence
take who you are whether they tell you
it's right or wrong or whatever maybe
if you fight day to day
and a struggle being who you are don't
let nobody ever tell you you're wrong
for that
don't let this world take that whether
it's a soccer player whether it's
a gang banger whether it's a homosexual
whatever it may be
don't let this world take your asses
because
that's what this role wants to do
what personality personality traits do
you have that kind of help you
get by in the world
um i say understanding
um i appreciate the people out there on
the street
because that's struggle that's worry
that's stress
what you're gonna wear to you're selling
soccer on saturday that any stress
what you're arguing if you're going to
save leftovers to throw them in the
trash
that's not stress that's wastefulness
that's stress out there
trying to fight something trying to
understand yourself and why
you rather sit on the curb and drink a
bottle of alcohol while your wife passes
down the heat next to you
and just watch it that's stress that's
worry
that's why i appreciate them even though
they don't appreciate themselves
someone's gotta appreciate it and i
don't know it's
i got a lot going on my head and [ __ ] um
so it's
you know last year's been right for me
so i choke up a lot lately
no it's a you fight the fight i don't
understand that that's what they'll
understand my life
what was the hardest part of your life
being in prison
no uh uh i'm a fighter by nature so
that's not
um not a fighter in a sense i cause
chaos but
i'm a stand-up guy by nature so i'm not
gonna
getting over the mental struggle
and like sure i had to go through after
my uncle was to me
that's probably it and
um not ever
not never been able to uh
know or experience a
genuine honest type of love
not just relationship but for anybody
your parents parents anybody
everybody's coming my life say they love
me [ __ ]
do you feel like you've ever been loved
no
no
what what regrets do you have looking
back to your life
um
i don't regret i don't regret nothing
about my life
um
because i love who i am so i can't
regret nothing else i regret myself but
dang i don't
i don't know um you don't have any
regrets at some point no i don't have no
regrets that's okay
yeah nothing wrong with that no i don't
regret
appreciate everything god's given me
good and bad are you religious
i'm not released um i believe in god
i uh
got the light on inside me i'm not
religious though that's
what do you think the the gang life
helped you with
what kind of things did you learn there
um
if you take it that way and take it with
a grain of salt
and you experience between experience
and learn from it you become a better
man
you become um
an understanding man a patient man
all right lucky thank you so much for
talking with me no thank you for letting
me i apologize if any questions i didn't
answer right
no you did great excellent good luck
with everything
appreciate it
you